[OPENING CREDITS]
FELIPE HOFFA: Hello, everyone.
I'm Felipe Hoffa, a Google
Cloud developer advocate.
And my job is to share with
you the most interesting data
sets I know, and the
Google Cloud tools that you
can use to explore them.
Today, I'm here with
Dr. Alexandre Passant,
a PhD in computer
science, and semantic web.
And he has been analyzing and
discovering music for the last
years in his blog--
what's the title--
DR. ALEXANDRE
PASSANT: Apassant.net.
That's my personal
blog where I regularly
publish about music
tech and data science.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes and
Alexandre recently
published this book "MusicTech"
from where he has the best
articles from his blog.
Check it out.
Today we're going
to talk about that.
How he has been researching
music, discovering music,
looking at different data sets.
So thank you for coming.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
Thanks for having me.
FELIPE HOFFA: Tell me more.
Can you tell me more how you
first started in music, where
you're looking at it.
DR. ALEXANDRE
PASSANT: Yeah so, I've
been doing my PhD in computer
science and semantic web, so
for the past five,
seven years maybe.
I was working on ways to
make that on the web smarter,
so we can use that more
easily for discovery,
customization,
recommendations, and so on.
And I'm also a big music
fan, playing music,
collecting records,
so I just decided
to combine both and see
what kind of insight
we can get from various
kind of data on the web,
to [INAUDIBLE] music
discovery tools.
FELIPE HOFFA: So can you
tell me more about why music,
what you're doing with it.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Sure.
So I've been doing
a PhD, as we said,
in computer science
and semantic web.
So during my PhD and
afterwards, my goal
was to find ways to
make data on the web
smarter, so that we can
use that for customization,
recommendation,
discovery and so on.
And I'm also a big music
fan, collecting records,
playing music, so I just
decided to merge both and see
what we can learn
from data bought music
on the web, whether it's
acoustic properties of a song,
or it's how people share
data or why [INAUDIBLE]
data and music in Wikipedia
or Twitter or YouTube.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah,
so you're working
with very interesting
data sets-- well,
what data sets have
you been using?
DR. ALEXANDRE
PASSANT: Well, so I've
been using lots of different
things from how people edit
pages on Wikipedia
to how people share
music on YouTube, for instance,
as well as different data set
playlists, or things like
using music API to learn
about the tempo of a song,
or [INAUDIBLE] properties
like [INAUDIBLE] and
these kinds of things.
FELIPE HOFFA: Um, how
big are these data sets?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
That varies, for instance.
One use is that
we've talked about I
was using 500,000 playlists.
Another one I'm using,
lots of different edits
for Wikipedia, 200 million
edits from Wikipedia.
So that varies a lot.
The Twitter one's in
real time, so I'm also
trying to combine kind of
study data and real time data
for [INAUDIBLE]
FELIPE HOFFA: Cool, and so we
will head into the sample soon.
I want to know, what
tools are you using for--
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yeah,
so most of the tools-- well,
I'm using Python for
all the experiments
first in terms of language.
And what I'm trying to do as
well in-- in all these things
is try to use as much
as possible cloud based
architectures and APIs.
Just because I want
one of my goals
is to showcase how we
can do all these things
without necessarily
having to set up
your own clusters of
machine that will do things
from big data analysis to
machine learning and so
on, in that particular
use because I'm
using BigQuery a lot.
Just because it's
pretty easy to set up.
It's easy to put
data, whether you
want to put big dumps
of data or if you
want to put streaming data.
It's also very fast and
very cost effective.
So that's very nice too when
you want to analyze data.
If you know SQL and just want
to do SQL on large data sets.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, it is.
So one of the examples
you have on the book
is how to look at
similar artists
based on Wikipedia data.
How are you doing that?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
Yes, so generally, the idea
was-- if you look at Wikipedia
that generally used to extract
information about the content.
Like you have a
page about an artist
and from there you can
have the genre to play,
you can have
influences, and so on.
So they're going to
do something different
and look at how people
edit Wikipedia pages,
and see from those edits if
you can infer correlations.
So if you use Amazon, if
you buy stuff on Amazon,
you have these things.
People who bought
that also bought this.
And the idea was to do something
similar with Wikipedia did.
So people who edit this
page, also edit that one.
And see if you can find relation
if you're an artist based
on the way people read pages.
FELIPE HOFFA: I see.
So you're looking at people
that edited this page also
edited this other artist.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Exactly.
FELIPE HOFFA: So can we
take a look at this example?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Sure.
Yes.
So for that, I'm using
the public Wikipedia edits
data sets which
is one of the data
sets you're sharing with
the-- with BigQuery.
That's the big data set.
So anyone can run a
similar experiment.
And if you look
at the data sets,
you'll see that for
every Wikipedia edit,
so we have the title
and the ID of the page.
And you have also
the contributor ID.
So that's what we need
to run that [INAUDIBLE]
because when you have
this information,
you can find that people who
edited a particular page also
edited another one, and
that's how we-- we're
building that first use case.
So let me get the
query from there.
And go in detail.
FELIPE HOFFA: How
big is this data set?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: The
data set is 300 million rows,
I think.
FELIPE HOFFA: Excellent.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: So
FELIPE HOFFA: Pass a query here?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
Run the query here.
So what that query does
there, I took the page
of the clash, the vendor-- and
FELIPE HOFFA: So the
clash is number 3043--
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
Yeah so that's
the idea of the
page in Wikipedia.
So every page got an ID, and the
ID won't change in real time.
So you can use the ID to
make those kind of queries.
So, that subquery there
will find all the people
that contributed to that page.
I am excluding the
bots there, because we
want to get real edits.
And I am also excluding
minor contributions
which can be just people
fixing a comma or typo.
And there from that
list, I'm getting simply
all the other pages that
those people have edited.
FELIPE HOFFA: And counting--
and ranking them by--
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Ranking
them by the number of edits.
So, lets run that
and see what we have.
So that query is very fast.
It was in the cache.
But we see that there
was other query,
text only five or
six [INAUDIBLE]
two pairs this
300 million words.
FELIPE HOFFA: So in
the results here,
we're getting
[INAUDIBLE] Hamilton.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yeah,
so we have very strange things,
cause in a way, they're
kind of mainstream.
So you see that people also
edit pages that have nothing
to do with them, like every
Elvis Presley or Janet Jackson.
FELIPE HOFFA: But
we're getting music.
Music is close enough.
DR. ALEXANDRE
PASSANT: Yeah, we're
still getting
[INAUDIBLE], like music.
There with relevant things
like the Sex Pistols,
the Ramones, which are--
which you can find actually
in a-- in a mus--
in a radio station,
like if you take a radio
on Spotify or something,
if you play The Clash, chances
are high that at some stage
you will have the Sex
Pistols or the Ramones.
And we have them here
just because on the web,
people edited the page.
FELIPE HOFFA: So we're
immediately getting results.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: So
but let's take something
maybe a bit different.
So, what we have
there is [INAUDIBLE].
Let's take Motorhead
for instance,
and see if we have
other-- Motorhead.
FELIPE HOFFA: What artist
now we are going to look?
What artist are
similar to Motorhead?
Based on the--
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
Based on the way people--
FELIPE HOFFA: Of edits.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Edits.
And we haven't run
that query yet,
so we'll see how much time
it takes without any cache.
FELIPE HOFFA: Excellent.
So we're going over--
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Process--
Bit more than 200 million.
FELIPE HOFFA: It process--
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
Seven seconds.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, seven
seconds to process [INAUDIBLE].
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
That's not too bad.
FELIPE HOFFA: Look
at the relationships.
And we're getting
[INAUDIBLE] the music.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
Yeah Motown music.
Found out [INAUDIBLE]
Guns and Roses.
Things that are not music
like mascara, for instance.
One way you can filter
that, is using for instance
an external data set like
Frida's, that will give us
additional information
about every page,
and we will know if a page
is about a musician or about
a movie and so on.
And actually, one
of the things I've
done with Twitter
and YouTube, we're
using that, so can
show you that later.
But like if you just
look at the music bins,
you have, like, yeah,
Warcraft and Guns and Roses.
FELIPE HOFFA: We're getting
interesting results already.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yes.
Yeah.
There's still strange
thing, but that's
in a way start conversion and
make things more interesting.
FELIPE HOFFA: And then you
jump to work with playlists.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
Tell me more about
these playlists.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yeah, so,
these are the streaming music
platform.
They have an API where you can
get information about artists,
about records and so on.
But that's not
with the playlists.
So what I've done there was
to get from that API 500,000
playlists, and then
put that into BigQuery.
And start running analysis.
So one of the nice
things there-- and that's
also a nice thing
about BigQuery when
you want to run ETL
pipeline or data
analysis, is that you can
directly push Gs on data
into BigQuery, as
long as [INAUDIBLE]
So you don't have
to do it inETL.
You just put the Gs
on like in that case,
like the one that was
provided by Geezer.
And just try to scheme
out, let's say, well,
in those-- in those
files we love.
We have an artist.
And the playlist will have
a track, on multiple tracks,
and every track will have
an artist, and so on.
That's-- you just
define the Gs on schema,
and give that to BigQuery, and
they will correct the tables
and all the content for you.
FELIPE HOFFA: So you don't know
that half a million playlists
from Deezer to this JSON
data directly into BigQuery.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Can we
look at the table just
to see the structure?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: So we
look-- we have the data there.
So, that's for a playlist, so
a playlist got a rating and ID.
You can have things like
title duration and so on.
And we'll see that
for every playlist,
we get a number of tracks.
So those are recurs,
that can be repeated.
And a track got some artists.
Every artist got an
ID and then the track
also got an album ID
and so on, and so on.
So what's interesting
is that that directly
comes from the Deezer API.
So let me show you.
If you look at the--
FELIPE HOFFA: These
are playlists?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
Original thing there.
So that's the Gs on
that I used to translate
the Gs on that comes
from that, from Geezer
directly to BigQuery.
So instead of running an
extraction on every result
I got from the API to
transfer-- transform their Gson
into a sequence to push
that in your data base.
You just directly pass the
Gs on with that kind of--
FELIPE HOFFA: Using that schema?
DR. ALEXANDRE
PASSANT: So the schema
says what we've seen
in the database.
We have a rating and ID, and
then we have some tracks,
and each track is a
recur that contains
a repeated number of artists,
and every artist also--
or every track of on an album.
And as a single
title, and so on.
FELIPE HOFFA: And what can
you do with this data, now
that you have--
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Half a million
playlists from a lot of people.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: So,
you can do lots of things.
So the obvious one is just if
you for instance want to find
what's popular, or what's--
what's most popular.
You can just simple--
very simple com queries.
So that's simple,
that's not very fun,
because there's
no real analytics.
But what you can do is use a
similar approach to what we've
just seen with
Wikipedia, is to find
similarities between artists.
So people that use that
artist in a playlist, what are
the other artist that they use?
In a sense, that means that
if they put artists together,
there's probably a similarity
at least for people, obviously.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's
have some queries
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yes.
So we take that one, so
for instance, that just--
FELIPE HOFFA: Rhianna.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Rhianna.
So that just takes--
that query table there.
Find the artists that
are similar to Rhianna
based on the number of playlists
that have been together.
So just joining the
playlists together with ID,
and make sure that
the artist that you--
to find other artists that
have been included in playlists
included Rhianna.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's
look at what artists
are similar to Rhianna based
on appearances on playlists.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Exactly.
So once again,
500,000 playlists.
Every playlist-- I don't
have the exact number,
but between 10 and 50 tracks.
And that's what we have there.
I think like Britney Spears,
Beyonce, [INAUDIBLE],
David Guetta, and so on.
So that's-- that's also kind
of the way-- if you look--
I've done something as well,
to use that in compared
to recommendation they're giving
to existing streaming platform.
And you see as well
there's some overlap.
So, having the sample is
in a way, relatively small
compared to the
number of playlists
that Spotify or Deezer can
have in full-- there are still
some [INAUDIBLE] there.
FELIPE HOFFA: And in very
few seconds, you can--
DR. ALEXANDRE
PASSANT: Yes, yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: You can
start clustering artists.
DR. ALEXANDRE
PASSANT: It took just
like six seconds for
500 gigs that's there.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
But you can do also--
so that one is artists--
to artist recommendations.
But we can do song
recommendations.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh, you can go as
deep as finding similar songs?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yes.
So let's say, for instance--
and you can do more than that.
You can do-- find
similar songs, but if you
want to make it that more
fun, exclude the songs
from the same artist.
So let's say, that
example there-- we
take "Harder, Faster, Better--"
"Harder, Better, Faster,
Stronger" from Daft Punk.
FELIPE HOFFA: OK.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: And
we find all the other tracks
that people play
together with that one,
excluding the Daft Punk tracks.
So that might be
a way-- and if you
want to build your own radio
station, you can just use that,
and say well, this
is the track I like.
Just that track from Daft Punk.
What you listen to
now but something
different from Daft Punk.
So the same kind of query that
instead of finding artists that
are together and
finding tracks that are
correlated in the same place.
FELIPE HOFFA: From
different artists?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yes,
from different artists.
So there I'm
excluding the artist,
which is that there-- that's
the idea of Daft Punk in Deezer.
That's the idea of that track.
So, running the query--
FELIPE HOFFA: Wow.
That was fast.
It was cached.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
Yes, it was cached.
But 12 like-- things that
David Guetta, [INAUDIBLE],
and so on, Bob Sinclair.
Then there are
things that might be
not in the same musical genre.
But just you have like Justice
and other French band playing
as well.
FELIPE HOFFA: People are
grouping them together.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yes
which-- which makes sense
if you think of it.
FELIPE HOFFA: Cool.
So from one track, you're
getting more recommendations,
tracks from other
artists, and looking
at the use of generated data--
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: From
this playlist.
Um, from our last
sample, I know you
have worked with streaming
data too with things
that are happening now.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Can you
tell me more about that?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Sure.
So, these two examples
are kind of static,
in the sense that we
took a bunch of data that
was done for a static
period of time,
and pass that into BigQuery
to run the analysis.
But I've used as well Twitter
and the Twitter stream
to find what are people
sharing in almost real time,
and see from there if we can
find from the Twitter firehose,
at least, from the one we have
from the API, which is subsets.
But what are the top tracks for
a given genre for the past 24
hours or 12 hours.
FELIPE HOFFA: So sounds
that people are sharing now,
I take it?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yes, yes.
And for that, I'm
using the songs
that people share
using YouTube links.
And the reason is that YouTube
got this API where you can get
additional data from Frida's.
So that means for every YouTube
link that's shared on Twitter,
I can get additional information
about who is the artist,
and what is the general
genre of the artist.
So then you can find--
give me the last pop music
or heavy metal music that
has been shared popularly
in the past 12 hours.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
And you are downloading
getting this data in real time
from Twitter?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
I want to make a big call
out here for our friends
at Twitter.
Ryan Choi at Twitter
developer relations
has published this
project where you
can collect your own
tweets using Google Compute
engine as you're doing now.
And you can run it for
yourself, look at their GitHub
to find this project.
So let's see how-- what are
you capturing right now?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
So I can show you
for the-- so I have an
instance running right now,
which gets data
from the firehose.
FELIPE HOFFA: So this is
how [INAUDIBLE] compute--
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Compute engine?
DR. ALEXANDRE
PASSANT: [INAUDIBLE]
fetching the Twitter stream API.
So it's fetching right now.
We have the tweets
coming from the API.
And each of these 280's
then, so the YouTube link
is extracted, passed
to the YouTube API
to get the Frida's IDs.
FELIPE HOFFA: So these are
Tweets that mention YouTube?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yes--
mentioned YouTube links.
So I-- the link then,
is sent to the YouTube
API to get the Frida's IDs.
So that's the entities that
are contained in a video.
So for a music video,
generally, as the ID back,
you have the Frida's
ID of the artist,
and the Frida's ID of the track.
And then the second step is
to code the Frida's API using
those IDs, and to get more
information about the artist.
So [INAUDIBLE]
could have their--
to get their music and genre.
So that's all done in real
time, because then one,
I get that data
back from Frida's.
I'm sending that to BigQuery
using the BigQuery stream API.
So that means that, like,
the time between the tweets
is published and the time its
in BigQuery is just a few--
less than a minute [INAUDIBLE].
FELIPE HOFFA: So you take
tweet, the YouTube link,
you have reached this
data, with Frida's data.
What's the artist?
What's the genre?
Nice.
Can we look at the table here?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Sure.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's
leave this out.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: So that's
a search of the table there.
So like in the-- these are use
case passing Gs on objects,
I'm flattening then to there.
So we have a tweet
there that contains--
so that's sort of the
information about the tweet, so
the question that
user, and so on.
And then inside the tweet,
there is a YouTube video.
It will have a
title, a description,
and this video has some topics.
And every topic gets
an ID and a type.
So the type comes from
Frida's as well as the ID,
but the type can be music
genre, or music artist.
And that's how using the
genre, I run the [INAUDIBLE],
so we can--
FELIPE HOFFA: What kind of
information are you extracting
[INAUDIBLE]-- extracting
from this blank data?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
One thing you can do
is to-- let's say what we
can-- look at that together.
But you can even find what
other popular genres that
are published during
the past 24 or 12 hours,
and then go deeper and look
just at one particular genre,
and see what people
post about it.
So that's let's take
that query there.
So that query-- and then that's
interesting there because we
see a combination of Twitter
information and Frida's.
So we've just seen
in the structure
that we have some
free base types.
So there I'm just finding all
types-- all instances of types,
music genres-- all the
genres-- that have been shared,
in the past hour--
FELIPE HOFFA: The last 24 hours.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: 24 hours.
And then for each of them,
finding the number of videos
and grouping that by
the number of videos.
That query will give us
the most popular genres
that have been extracted from
the-- from the data sets.
FELIPE HOFFA:
Let's look at that.
Again, [INAUDIBLE] gigabytes?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: Less
than three seconds?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
Less than three seconds.
So that's the number of
videos there extracted.
FELIPE HOFFA: We get
the free base ID.
DR. ALEXANDRE
PASSANT: Yes so that's
the free base ID of the genre.
And that's what we have
in our, you know, sample.
FELIPE HOFFA: Pop music, hip
hop music, rock, acoustic,
soundtracks.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Right.
So we can take
one, for instance.
Let's take alternative
rock there.
And there I have the query.
FELIPE HOFFA:
We're going to look
at what are the most
popular songs for a genre?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
Yes for the past--
in that case, 24 hours.
So we'll take--
FELIPE HOFFA: Alternative rock?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
And we'll find--
FELIPE HOFFA: We put
the free base ID there?
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
The free base ID there.
The free base ID can
be either in the topic
of the relevant topic.
Because that's the way that
your API gives you back results.
That's in a way to find
what's the primary topic,
and subtopics.
But then, I'm using
the genre for both.
And we'll see again--
FELIPE HOFFA: The last 24 hours.
DR. ALEXANDRE
PASSANT: And that will
be run as well by the number of
tweets for a particular video.
So that's not the
number of tweets.
That's the number of videos.
So grouping by video
numbers and not [INAUDIBLE].
Once, again, we still have
this-- yeah, 1.5 gigabytes
in about two seconds.
FELIPE HOFFA: Two seconds.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: And there
are things like what's in--
FELIPE HOFFA: [INAUDIBLE],
Greenday, Radiohead.
Nice.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: So
that's-- that's the kind
of thing that have been
extracted from that stream,
which is, again, not
the first stream.
But that gives an idea
of the kind of data
you can do with
the Twitter stream.
There are lots of things that
are shown there on YouTube
and then filtering
only by music,
and then passing that
to-- to free base,
you can run that
kind of thing, so--
FELIPE HOFFA: And I know you
created a website [INAUDIBLE]
DR. ALEXANDRE
PASSANT: Yeah, there
is a smaller company on the
website, I'd go with that.
That just show basically
what are during the past 24
hours-- the 24
most popular genres
and for each of them, the
24 most popular tracks.
So that's there and you
can filter by genres,
so you can find the
last electronic music
tracks that have been
shared in the 24 hours.
You can come back to
indie rock as well
and the Arctic Monkeys,
The Strokes, and so on,
or whatever genre you want.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: That
just-- yeah, the tech industry
and then running the query
to-- so there, what you see
there is not done in real time.
But every few hours, there's
a [INAUDIBLE] query-- BigQuery
to prepare the [INAUDIBLE].
FELIPE HOFFA: So
in real time, you
are analyzing tweets, and
reading them, and discovering
music through it.
That's awesome.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT:
Yeah, that's quite fun.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's what
we have for today, I think.
Thank you, Alexandre,
for coming.
Everyone, check his
blog, check his book.
So [INAUDIBLE], to get
more big data stories.
Stay curious, from
[INAUDIBLE] and Felipe Hoffa.
DR. ALEXANDRE PASSANT: Thanks.